(seufzt:) Klimakrise.
Man hatte es
schon fast wieder vergessen.
Putins Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine
bringt nicht nur viel Leid,
sondern auch die Erkenntnis,
wir müssen dringend raus
aus Gas, Öl und Kohle.
Wegen Umwelt und Klima sowieso,
aber auch:
Ja, wären wir jetzt nur bloß weiter
mit unserer grünen Energiewende.
Wir wissen schon lange:
"Dass die einzige Energieform,
die niemandem gehört,
wo auch keiner sagen kann,
alles meins, damit erpress ich euch,
Wind und Sonne ist."
"Die gehören der Menschheit.
Man muss sie nur auffangen."
Genau!
Also ...
Nicht ganz genau.
Klar, Wind und Sonne gibt es überall,
und sie gehen nicht aus.
Das heißt aber nicht,
dass man überall beliebig viel
davon auffangen
und nutzen kann.
Wir können zwar, und müssen,
Solar- und Windenergie
in Deutschland deutlich ausbauen,
aber um unseren gesamten
Energiebedarf zu decken,
inklusive Industrie,
Flug- und Schwerlastverkehr,
werden wir auch grüne Energie
importieren müssen,
zum Beispiel in Form
von grünem Wasserstoff.
Millionentonnenweise.
Wer da 'ne Wüste
und all-you-can-Solarstrom
vor der Tür hat, ist klar im Vorteil.
Deswegen baut etwa Saudi-Arabien
seine Wasserstoffproduktion aus.
Wind und Sonne
machen uns unabhängiger ...
aber wenn wir in Zukunft immer noch
auf Importe angewiesen sind,
ist das dann nicht
dasselbe Problem in Grün?
Pan-intended.
Werden wir dann zukünftig
solche Schlagzeilen haben?
Oder können wir
mithilfe von Technologien
und besonders effizienter Nutzung
von erneuerbaren Energien
in Zukunft doch energieautark werden,
also uns komplett selbst versorgen?
Die kurze Antwort
auf beide Fragen ist: Nein.
Für die lange Antwort holt euch
'nen Tee, macht's euch gemütlich.
Wir steigen durch.
(Belebte Musik)
Fangen wir wie immer ganz vorne an
und schauen uns an,
wovon wir überhaupt reden.
"Energie."
Vielbenutztes Wort,
aber sehr abstrakt,
also machen wir's anschaulich.
Kapitel eins:
Dieses Gummiband hat wenig Energie.
Jetzt hat es mehr.
Und jetzt ist die Energie wieder weg.
Nein, nicht wirklich weg.
(Sie liest vor.)
Zum Beispiel wandle ich
die Energie meiner Handbewegung
in Spannungsenergie um.
Wenn ich die Spannung löse,
verschwindet die Energie nicht,
sondern wird
in Bewegungsenergie umgewandelt.
Das große Kraftwerk,
das so gut wie alles Leben
auf diesem Planeten antreibt,
ist die Sonne - Freunde der Sonne.
Pflanzen nutzen
ihre Strahlungsenergie
für Fotosynthese.
Fotosynthese ist die chemische
Umwandlung von CO2 in ...
ja, in Pflanze basically.
Dadurch wird CO2 gebunden
in Form von Blättern, Blüten
Baumstämmen oder Erdbeeren.
Es braucht also Sonnenenergie,
um das C aus dem kleinen CO2
zu größeren C-Verbindungen
wie Zucker, Stärke
oder Zellulose zusammenzusetzen.
Diese Energie wird vor allem
in den Bindungen
zwischen den C-Atomen gespeichert.
Wenn wir Pflanzen essen und
die chemischen Bindungen aufbrechen,
setzen wir Energie frei, mit der wir
sämtliche Körperfunktionen betreiben.
Wir machen das Gegenteil
von Fotosynthese:
Wir verbrennen
energiereiche Verbindungen
zu Wasser und CO2,
das wir dann wieder ausatmen.
Und dieses CO2 können die Pflanzen
dann wieder nutzen für Fotosynthese.
Ein Gleichgewicht,
der Kohlenstoffkreislauf,
the circle of life.
(Triumphierende Rufe)
Bis wir Menschen mal wieder
alles kaputtgemacht haben.
Für unser modernes Leben
brauchen wir sehr viel Wärme,
sehr viel Strom.
Einfach sehr viel Energie,
und die holen wir uns immer noch
zum größten Teil,
indem wir fossile Energiequellen,
Kohle, Erdöl oder Erdgas, verbrennen,
um die sweet, sweet Bindungsenergie
freizusetzen,
die in diesen hochkonzentrierten
Kohlenstoffmaterialien steckt.
Öl und Gas etwa bestehen letztendlich
aus toten Pflanzen,
die über Millionen Jahre unter
der Erde zusammengedrückt wurden.
Das heißt, all das CO2, das diese
Pflanzen über Millionen von Jahren
der Erdatmosphäre entzogen
und in pflanzenform gebunden haben,
setzen wir durchs Verbrennen
dann schlagartig wieder frei
und blasen's in die Luft.
(Klirren)
Dafür ist der Kohlenstoffkreislauf
nicht ausgelegt.
So war das nicht ausgemacht.
Es ist ja dann gar kein Circle mehr,
sondern the one way street of life.
Und so steigen CO2-Gehalt
unserer Atmosphäre
und Erderwärmung stetig an.
Tschüss Gleichgewicht.
Hallo Klimakrise, alter Freund.
Kapitel zwei:
Wind- und Solarkraft
haben gleich mehrere Vorteile:
Sie beruhen nicht auf Verbrennung,
das heißt, auf CO2-Ausstoß.
Sie verschmutzen nicht die Luft.
Und sie sind natürlich erneuerbar,
das heißt, sie gehen nicht aus.
Aber die Sonne scheint nicht immer.
Der Wind weht auch nicht immer.
Außer vielleicht in der
Commonwealth-Bucht in der Antarktis,
dem laut Guinness-Buch
windigsten Ort der Welt.
Warte mal,
3,5 von vier Sternen bei Maps?
(Es wird vorgelesen.)
Ähm ...
wo war ich? Ach so!
So nennt man Zeiträume
mit zu wenig Sonnenschein und Wind,
die man überbrücken muss.
Womit?
Na ja, Kraftwerke, die besonders gut
für Dunkelflauten geeignet sind,
weil sie lange stillliegen und
bei Bedarf schnell anspringen können,
sind ... Gaskraftwerke.
Ja, das heißt, selbst wenn wir alles
mit Solarzellen
und Windrädern vollpflastern,
wären wir wegen der Dunkelflauten
immer noch abhängig von Erdgas.
Um die grüne Energiewende
zu 100 Prozent zu meistern,
brauchen wir also:
Immer wenn der Wind weht
oder die Sonne scheint,
die Energie sammeln, speichern
und bei Bedarf abrufen.
Für solche Speichertechnologien
gibt es viele Möglichkeiten.
Klassiker, kann man natürlich auch
mit grünem Strom beladen
und bei Bedarf entladen.
Mit grünem Strom
etwa in einen Stausee pumpen,
bei Bedarf wieder abfließen lassen
und Turbinen antreiben.
Mit grünem Strom
einen Tank Flüssigsalz erhitzen,
dass eine hohe Wärmekapazität hat und
Hitze eine gute Weile halten kann.
Das Speichern mit Hitze
ist deswegen so cool,
weil unsere Kraftwerke typischerweise
Wärmekraftmaschinen sind.
Also Maschinen, die Wärmeenergie
in Bewegungsenergie umwandeln.
In der Regel wird Wasser erhitzt,
also durch das Verbrennen
von Kohle, Öl oder Gas,
verdampft, und der heiße Wasserdampf
treibt Dampfturbinen an.
Die Idee ist jetzt,
dieses Erhitzen stattdessen
mit etwa einem Flüssigsalzspeicher
zu machen.
So könnte man bestehende Kraftwerke
umrüsten zu grünen Kraftwerken.
Dann gibt's noch Energiespeicher
in Form von Kraftstoff:
Man nimmt Wasser und Strom,
grünen Strom natürlich,
und macht daraus
Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff.
Den Wasserstoff nutzt man dann,
indem man ihn wieder verbrennt.
Da Verbrennungen, chemisch gesehen,
nichts anderes sind
als die Reaktion mit Sauerstoff,
entsteht dadurch
H2 plus O2 gleich H2O,
Wasser als Abgas.
So viel jetzt erst mal
an dieser Stelle
in aller Kürze und Unvollständigkeit.
Ihr seht,
es gibt viele Lösungsansätze.
Das ist auch gut so.
Denn wir werden viele brauchen.
Es gibt nicht die eine Master-Lösung.
Und viele dieser Technologien
sind derzeit noch in Entwicklung
und noch nicht
in der breiten Anwendung.
Aber:
"Einige Schlüsseltechnologien,
wie Batterien, Wind oder Solar,
haben sich auch
viel besser entwickelt
als man das ... als selbst Experten
das erwartet haben."
"Seit 2010 sind die Kosten für Solar-
und Windenergie oder Batterien
um bis zu 85 Prozent gesunken."
Ja, dieses positive Gefühl,
das ihr grade verspürt,
fühlt sich ungewohnt und falsch an.
Aber es gibt,
auch bei der Klimakrise,
tatsächlich Grund zum Optimismus.
Aber Gutes passiert
natürlich nicht automatisch.
Kapitel drei:
Auch wenn uns Sonne und Wind
nicht ausgehen,
können wir ja trotzdem nicht
unendlich viel
davon ernten und nutzen.
Wir haben etwa eine begrenzte Fläche,
wir können ja nicht beliebig viele
Solarpanels und Windräder aufstellen.
Auch wenn es deutlich
mehr sein könnten als heute.
Dass erneuerbare Energien
pro Energieeinheit
so viel Fläche brauchen,
ist ein Nachteil.
Wir brauchen die Fläche
schließlich auch für Landwirtschaft
und Naturschutz.
Wenn wir fragen,
schaffen wir die Energiewende,
meinen wir damit ja:
Können wir
mit unseren begrenzten Möglichkeiten
ausreichend Energie herstellen?
Die Antwort ist:
Ja, wenn wir die Energie
möglichst effizient nutzen.
Okay, wie geht Effizienz?
Erstens: durch bessere Technologien.
Also, moderne Solarzellen heute sind
schon etwa doppelt so ertragreich
wie ältere Modelle.
Das heißt, ich kriege
mit der gleichen Sonnenenergie
doppelt so viel Strom raus.
Was die Ingenieur:innen
da verbessert haben, ist der:
Gibt man typischerweise
in Prozent an.
Beispiel: Der Wirkungsgrad
eines Autoverbrennungsmotors
ist 40 Prozent.
Das bedeutet, nur 40 Prozent
der dem Motor zugeführten Energie
wird auch tatsächlich
in Leistung umgesetzt.
Die restlichen 60 Prozent
gehen etwa durch Reibung
in Form von Wärme verloren.
Also, "verloren", ist klar,
Erster Hauptsatz
der Thermodynamik, verloren,
weil diese Wärme nicht genutzt wird.
Gleiches beim E-Auto.
Das Laden des E-Autos
und auch wieder das Entladen,
also das Fahren,
sind beides Umwandlungsprozesse,
bei denen Energie verlorengeht.
Wenn ich jetzt aber mein E-Auto mit
einer bestimmten Strommenge lade,
kann ich damit
deutlich weiter fahren,
als wenn ich mit derselben Strommenge
synthetischen Kraftstoff herstelle,
und den dann in 'nem normalen
Automotor verbrenne.
Weil Elektromotoren
einen höheren Wirkungsgrad haben
als Verbrennungsmotoren.
Und weil das Laden einer Batterie
einen höheren Wirkungsgrad hat
als das Herstellen
eines synthetischen Kraftstoffs.
Also, vom Wirkungsgrad her
sind E-Autos energieeffizienter
als Verbrenner,
die mit grünem Kraftstoff fahren.
Synthetische Kraftstoffe
und Wasserstoff sind da sinnvoll,
wo wir keine effizientere
grüne Alternative haben:
Flugzeuge, Schiffe,
der chemischen Industrie.
Okay, ich kann als Ingenieurin
durch Wirkungsgradoptimierung
den Anteil
der Verlustenergie reduzieren,
aber ich kann ihn nicht
komplett vermeiden.
Denn egal, was es ist, wenn ich
Sonnenenergie in Strom umwandle
oder potenzielle Stauseeenergie
in Bewegung,
am Ende krieg ich immer
weniger Energie raus,
als ich reingesteckt habe.
Dieses Prinzip ist
der Satz der Energieentwertung,
auch bekannt als:
Warum ist das wichtig?
Na ja, wenn bei
jedem Laden einer Batterie,
bei jedem Herstellen
eines Kraftstoffs,
bei jedem Verbrennen
Energie verlorengeht,
kommt es ja nicht nur
auf die einzelnen Wirkungsgrade an,
sondern auch darauf,
wie viele Maschinen oder Prozesse
ich hintereinanderschalte.
Je mehr, desto mehr Energie
geht mit jedem Schritt verloren.
Also, desto ineffizienter
wird das Ganze.
Wenn ich mit Solarstrom
ein Batterie lade
und damit dann nachts
mein Handy lade,
dann ist das weniger effizient,
als wenn ich das Handy
tagsüber bei Sonnenschein
direkt lade,
weil ich so
einen Umwandlungsschritt spare.
Das heißt, wie viel Energie ich
aus einem Windstoß
oder einem Sonnenstrahl rausbekomme,
hängt nicht nur davon ab,
wie gut unsre Ingenieure
die Wirkungsgrade optimieren,
sondern auch, wie direkt oder
indirekt diese Energie genutzt wird.
Je direkter, desto effizienter.
Es ist also schön und gut,
wenn wir unsere Häuser
mit Solarpanels ausstatten
und elektrischen Wärmepumpen
und Batterien für nachts,
aber so richtig effizient
wird's erst,
wenn wir uns vernetzen.
Sodass von Stellen
mit akutem Energieüberschuss
Energie fließen kann zu Stellen
mit akutem Bedarf, und andersrum.
Also möglichst viel direkt nutzen,
und nur so viel wie nötig speichern.
Und hier geht
die geopolitische Diskussion los.
Kapitel vier:
Keine Frage, akut müssen wir jetzt
erst mal so schnell wie möglich raus
aus der Abhängigkeit
von russischem Gas.
Da könnte man zu dem Schluss kommen,
dass die Energiewende
auch die Chance ist,
uns in Zukunft
geopolitisch unabhängig zu machen,
indem wir energieautark werden.
Das heißt, alles darauf setzen,
dass wir uns, entweder komplett
oder so gut wie möglich,
selbst versorgen können.
Mit fortgeschrittenerer
Speichertechnologie
wäre das technisch
vielleicht sogar möglich.
Tatsächlich ist das
aber gar nicht das Ziel.
Zumindest sollte es das nicht sein.
Natürlich müssen wir Wind-
und Solarkraft in Deutschland
noch rasant ausbauen.
Die Klimauhr tickt.
Aber genau wie man sich
in Deutschland vernetzen würde,
um regionalen Überschuss und Bedarf
auszugleichen,
wär's verschenkt, wenn man das nicht
über die Grenzen hinaus machen würde.
Wir haben ja schon
ein europäisches Stromnetz,
das sollte für den grünen Strom
weiter ausgebaut werden.
Der Weg in eine grüne Zukunft sollte
nicht zur Staatenautarkie werden.
Effiziente Vernetzung
und fairer Handel
lohnt sich wirtschaftlich
und ist gut für Klima und Umwelt.
Denn wir sollten global Flächen
möglichst effizient nutzen,
um möglichst viel Natur zu bewahren.
Problematisch wird's natürlich,
wenn große Abhängigkeiten
von wenigen Staaten
mit geopolitischen Machtinteressen
zusammenfallen.
Und sind wir nicht blauäugig:
Natürlich hätte Saudi-Arabien
nichts dagegen,
wenn supereffizient produzierte
grüne Energieträger aus Saudi-Arabien
irgendwann das neue Öl wären.
Aber die Machtverhältnisse
werden im Zuge der Energiewende
sich breiter verteilen und shiften,
was bestimmt noch eine geopolitisch
unruhige Zeit wird,
aber auch die Chance auf einen
deutlich diversifizierten Weltmarkt
und reduzierte Abhängigkeitsrisiken
bringt.
Das heißt, jetzt
in eine international diverse
und damit stabile Infrastruktur
investieren.
Gleichzeitig, nicht vergessen,
es gibt ja tatsächlich das "neue Öl"
oder das "neue Gas".
Das sind aber nicht Wind und Sonne,
das sind die Rohstoffe
wie Lithium oder Seltenerdmetalle,
ohne die man kein Windrad
und auch ein Solarpanel bauen kann,
auch keinen Computer oder Handy.
Und da ist grade China
bei den Seltenen Erden
weltweit der mit Abstand
größte Anbieter
und hat damit schon sehr viel Macht.
Ist ein Thema für sich.
Deswegen will ich das
auch gar nicht kleinreden.
Ich will damit nur sagen:
Selbst in einer Zukunft
mit 100 Prozent erneuerbaren Energien
wird es immer noch
globale Abhängigkeiten geben.
Und dafür ist jetzt auch die Zeit,
die richtigen
strategischen Weichen zu stellen.
Heißt unterm Strich: Go Energiewende!
"Energie!"
(Triumphale Musik)
Für alle,
die jetzt immer noch da sind,
vielen Dank für euer Interesse.
Ich weiß, "maiLab" war lange weg.
Ihr dachtet wahrscheinlich,
ihr seht mich hier nie wieder.
Aber zumindest in letzter Zeit
war der Grund tatsächlich
dieser grausame Angriffskrieg
auf die Ukraine.
Wir wollen ja immer
mit unseren Videos
einen Mehrwert generieren.
Und in dieser Situation ...
hatten wir, außer Betroffenheit,
einfach nicht
viel Hilfreiches zu sagen.
Es war jetzt einfach die Zeit
für andere Berichterstattungen.
Wir haben uns da zurückgenommen.
Ich find ja, wenn man nichts
Hilfreiches zu sagen hat,
kann man's auch lassen.
Hierzu wollten wir doch was sagen.
Es hat tatsächlich
sehr gut getan uns hier im Team
und sehr viel Spaß gemacht,
endlich wieder ein Video zu machen.
Also, wenn ihr Themenvorschläge
für nächste Videos habt,
schreibt sie gerne in die Kommentare.
Schaut bei unseren funk-Kollegen
von "DIE DA OBEN!" vorbei,
da kriegt ihr aktuell
sehr gute Einordnungen
zur deutschen Ukraine-Politik,
wie das hier zum Beispiel.
Und wir sehen uns bald.
Und bis bald mein ich ...
früher oder später.
Bis dahin: Bleibt sicher.
Ihr kennt doch "maiLab" -
ich komm immer wieder.